>> Tucker: DID HE NOT RECUSE
HIMSELF.
>> NOT AT ALL.
HE IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
>> Tucker: RUNNING THE D.C.
OFFICE.
>> THANK YOU.
BANNER OF THE LEFT IN THE
ELECTION.
SHE WAS GREEN PARTY
CANDIDATE.
NOW SHE HAS BEEN EXPOSED.
SHE WAS A RUSSIAN SPY ALL
ALONG.
THAT'S THE CLAIM, BELIEVE IT
OR NOT.
TWO SENATE COMMITTEES ARE
INVESTIGATING HER AS A
POSSIBLE CRONY OF THE
KREMLIN.
HER SINS INCLUDE APPEARING
ON RT, THAT'S THE RUSSIAN
TELEVISION CHANNEL RUSSIA
TODAY AND ATTEND AGO DINNER
IN 2015 WHERE SHE SAT AT THE
SAME TABLE AS VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
ALL OF WHICH MAKES HER A
MODERN MAD HARRY.
WHAT DOES SHE SAY IN HER
DEFENSE?
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
DR. STEIN, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU EVER
BEEN A AGENT OF RUSSIA.
DO YOU SPEAK RUSSIAN.
ARE YOU A FRIENDS OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> NOT AT ALL.
EVEN WHEN BRIEFLY HE SAT AT
FOR A CONFERENCE, ATTENDED
ACTUALLY BY THE BBC, BY THE
THIS WAS AN ACTUAL
LEGITIMATE CONFERENCE.
IT'S ALL UP ON THE WEB.
THERE IS NOTHING SECRET
PUTTING OUT PRESS RELEASES.
NO BACKROOM DEALS.
NO SECRET MEETINGS IN
OLIGARCHY TOWERS OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
ALL VERY TRANSPARENT AND
PUBLIC.
THE DINNER AT THE END OF THE
CONFERENCE WAS REALLY A
NONEVENT.
AT ONE POINT PUTIN CAME IN
WITH A COUPLE OF GUYS THAT I
ASSUMED WERE HIS BODY
GUARDS.
TURNS OUT THEY WERE ACTUALLY
HIS INNER CIRCLE, BUT YOU
WOULD HAVE NEVER KNOWN IT
NOBODY WAS INTRODUCED TO
ANYBODY.
THERE WALLS NO TRANSLATOR.
ACTUALLY, NO -- NOT A WORD
EXCHANGED.
AT ONE POINT PUTIN MADE A
VERY RAPID TURN AROUND THE
TABLE AND SHOOK EVERYBODY'S
SO THAT'S ABOUT AS
SIGNIFICANT AS THIS WAS.
>> Tucker: SOUNDS LIKE
COLLUSION TO ME.
SO, WAIT, CAN WE GET TO YOUR
REAL CRIME WHICH WAS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT AS THE THIRD
PARTY CANDIDATE.
IN THE VIEW OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON YOU GOT
DONALD TRUMP ELECTED.
DO YOU SEE THIS AS
PUNISHMENT FOR THE CRIME OF
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT?
>> YES.
IN MANY WAYS.
MANY OF THE ARTICLES LIKE
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" THREE
DAYS AGO IN ANNOUNCING THIS
INVESTIGATION BEGAN WITH A
QUOTE FROM A SPOKESPERSON OF
THE CAMPAIGN SAYING ISN'T
THIS GREAT BECAUSE SO MANY
CLINTON DEMOCRATS ARE
FURIOUS AT ME.
THEY ARE OUTRAGED THAT I
DARED IN SO MANY WORDS, YOU
KNOW, DARED TO THINK THAT WE
GET TO MAKE UP OUR OWN MINDS
THAT OUR VOTES DON'T BELONG
TO HILLARY CLINTON OR
ANYBODY ELSE.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
COMMISSION.
>> Tucker: I KNOW.
>> LED BY REPUBLICANS.
>> Tucker: I'M AWARE.
>> YEAH.
THEY HAVE IT IN AS WELL
BECAUSE IT'S VERY
INCONVENIENT TO HAVE AN
>> Tucker: LOOK, IF THEY
DISAGREE WITH WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING, AND FOR THE RECORD I
DISAGREE WITH ALMOST
EVERYTHING YOU SAY.
BUT IF YOU DISAGREE WITH
WHAT YOU SAY, WHY NOT ARGUE
AGAINST IT?
WHY TRY TO PRETEND THAT YOU
THAT SEEMS LIKE MCCARTHYISM
TO ME.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU ARE NOT THE
LET ME SAY I THINK THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE AIMS HERE.
IS MUCH BIGGER THAN THE
RUSSIANS.
AND WE HAVE YET TO SEAT
PROOF.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEAT
EVIDENCE OF RUSSIAN
CULPABILITY HERE WHEN JOHN
KENNEDY, YOU KNOW, WAS
FACING THE CUBAN MISSILE
CRISIS, HE DECLASSIFIED THE
IN CUBA.
YOU KNOW, AREN'T WE OWED
THE EVIDENCE BEFORE THE
RUN-UP TO THE IRAQ WAR.
WE ARE STILL PAYING THAT
PRICE.
$5.5 TRILLION AND COUNTING.
YOU KNOW,
YOU KNOW FOOL ME ONCE SHAME
ON YOU.
FOOL ME A GAZILLION TIMES
SHAME ON ALL OF US.
>> Tucker: LET ME REVISE
WHAT I SAID I ACTUALLY DO